Who is
the god like Yahweh the god
of wrath the god of Mercy The
God Who reaches down to unworthy
people.
Well, it is so great to see you church. I'm thankful that
at least a few of you have started up your thread game a
little bit with me on these last sermons of the series like this.
This is a tradition. I started now almost
12 years ago where out in Trinity
Baptist Church and Weatherford Oklahoma my first Pastor it we
began this because I I started
my pastor by preaching through the entire book of Ephesians and
I thought it was John mccarthur or something because I
was like 26 sermons through the whole book and it was limping to
the Finish Line where I was like man, I got to honor
their endurance through this thing and so we decided to
do this and it's just kind of stuck with it. And so it's fun but
thinking about sermons the hardest
part of any sermon is the conclusion the ending
It's like flying a plane The Landing is the the
most important part the most complicated part most
difficult part. I was I was with a
man in our church flying around in his little Cessna and and
I know I understand that taking off and cruising
it out. There's there's more to it than what it
seems like but I know for sure that the landing
is the most involved and most critical part.
It's the same with the sermon.
Like you can have a great flight.
And then as you get close to the airport, you just start circling and
circling and circling and then you can you can crash land
that thing and what do people walk out remembering of course,
is that Landing?
Even a serious can be similar to that. Whereas we
have now spent 13 weeks in the Book
of Micah in the Old Testament.
It's been so powerful.
It's been really challenging but now we've come to the end.
I actually thought about like playing The Boys to Men song
into the road, but I didn't think I'd be appropriate right now. You know,
that's the end of the
Road because I can't like I can't let go. I don't know so seriously, but
but as intimidating as this book was like
to me walking into this now a
few months ago.
As difficult as it has been to hear some of the things that God says to
us in it.
It's been such a sweet study.
I've been so good and I want to avoid Crash Landing this thing and so
I wanted to end well for us.
Well, thankfully the book itself comes to a beautiful conclusion.
I don't have to work very hard. It does it itself and
so take your copy of God's word and turn with me.
to the end of Micah
for the final time in this series Micah chapter
7 the very end last couple verses.
Now before we conclude this powerful book, we need to quickly review
where we've come so far.
Some of you might be jumping into this out of nowhere or at least just a
refresher for all of us.
We need to review where we've come and so we started this
whole thing by asking the question who is like
Yahweh.
Who is like Yahweh?
Do you remember why we asked that question at the beginning?
Because that's what the name Micah actually
means.
Who is like Yahweh. That's what his
very name is that from before Micah was even born
God called him as a prophet to
his people to the southern Kingdom of Judah primarily.
He did speak to the north, but mostly to the South and in
his very name Micah.
God chose Micah to be the one to call God's
people back to him.
Call God's people back to live this holy life
this set apart life. Micah was
primarily used for that purpose to remind
these people who God is and what he
says to them and then
In memory of who he is,
they should turn away from their idols and turn back to follow him.
That was a whole life Micah lived.
But in light of who God is as he
showed himself through this book that he's utterly distinct. He's holy
he's different.
It led us to the second question, which was who can
then Ascend to Yahweh.
Who is like Yahweh, but then who can ever
Ascend to him? That's the main image.
We've had throughout this entire series.
That right off the bat you remember in chapter 1 God comes down from his
holy mountain.
He descends to his people to judge
the Nations.
All of chapter one is Judgment that he is all-powerful.
He's lifted up high above everything. He's perfectly spotless.
And yet he came down to say you are not.
But one day he's going to renew and restore that
mountain as the dwelling place of
him and his people again, and so we are forced to
ask the question. Okay, how do we get there?
Like we want to be there with God. How do we get there who can
Ascend to that mountain of God to be with him? How
do we get there? Is it is it our effort?
Can we climb that mountain and get to him or or does
he somehow bring us up there with him?
That question was it behind the entire book of
Micah's who can Ascend to be with him?
We saw God's heart his character.
That he had empathy for the outcast. He desired
Purity in his people. And so the question then is
who can ever be with God if that's who he is.
Because we're not like that.
And we've seen hints of the answer throughout the book thankfully.
But it's really all been building to what we're going to see today in this
chapter.
Before we get there though. There's a third question. We've been asking throughout Micah.
In light of who God is in light of who he's called us as
his people to be will we then live for
him?
Who is like him who can Ascend to him will we then live
for him?
If we are his people if we claim to be as people
will live lives marked by his heart.
Changed by his character loving what he loves being
like him.
Because remember what Judah had been doing.
They've been stealing Land from the poor they'd been
taking bribes flaunting their evil. Deeds
cheating each other with deceitful weights. They
were worshiping Idols. They were playing with sorcery. They
were abandoning God in every way.
They were opposed. It was there's this old word antigoglin
that says that they were on they were not close
to what God wanted.
They were at odds with what he wanted their
crooked. You might say.
That's why Micah's call in Micah 6:8. If you
remember his call to act justly to love being
faithful to one another to walk humbly with
Yahweh. That's why it was so prophetic to
his people.
Because Micah was not comfortably surrounded by
those who agreed with him about those people
out there.
Like he's just tossing red meat to his fans like yeah, they're
terrible aren't they? And he's throwing throwing through no, he's turning around
and speaking God's truth to those who were supposed to be God's
people.
That's true Prophet. That's true prophetic Ministry.
Is when you're confronting your own people.
about their faults
That they were called to live lives of Holiness. They were
called the point other nations around them to Yahweh, but
they were not.
And so what was their hope then?
They've hit this place of crisis.
God has called them out repeatedly. If God is Holy if
God's on his holy mountain and if we're not holy what
hope do we have to ever be with him they were
saying
Same for us since all of sin and fall short of the glory of
God and we are due his wrath the
wages of sin is death. What hope do we have to be
with God ever again?
Well, that's how Micah concludes the book.
As we've reviewed the entire thing. This is how he concludes it.
He started with the character of God.
He infused the character of God throughout the book.
And now he lands the plane with the character of
God.
It's just about who God is.
But here's the difference.
He doesn't talk about the character of God in this way at this time at
the end of the book. He doesn't talk about it in a way to infuse
Terror into us.
He's not saying these things.
To say this is God be afraid of him. He's saying this is
who I know God to be.
Even towards sinful people like you and me. He's saying
I know who God is look at who he is verses 18
through 20.
Who is a God Like You?
Pardoning iniquity passing over
transgression for the remnant of his inheritance.
He does not retain his anger forever.
Because he Delights instead fast, love.
He will again have compassion on us. He will
tread our iniquities underfoot.
You God will cast all our sins into the depths of
the sea. You will show faithfulness to
Jacob and steadfast. Love to Abraham as you
have sworn to our fathers from the days of
old.
What a landing, right?
Beautiful powerful life-giving words to
land This Plane, but did you see how he began
the section?
Verse 18, he asked the question who is a
God Like You
this is the sandwich to his name at the beginning who
said who is like Yahweh. Now, he asked the question
at the very end. This book end. He says who's a God
Like You
Who is like Yahweh, who is a God Like You?
but notice
That this question this time is not asked in
a fearful kind of way, like what can ever who
could ever be with God like who is like Yahweh
and we're terrified of it. This is almost in an excited
kind of way like who is like Yahweh.
Who is like this God?
Who is like yeah, because everything he
writes after this these last three verses it's
positive, right?
that this is
a God who is utterly unique?
because of what he does for his people
Who is like this guy?
There's no other God like this.
Who is forgiving like this restoring like
this forgetting like this responding
like this? Who is like Yahweh, right?
But again, that's the whole point.
Micah was wanting his people to remember what
they had that nobody else had.
Not to become arrogant about that but to be changed by
that reality.
Mike is like God. Do you remember this is our God.
So be different live differently in light of
this not take it for granted and wander off
into your own selfish Pursuits Judah. You should remember
and draw near.
Is it not the same for us today?
Is this not the same challenge for us today?
That's why we keep coming back to the gospel to the
good news of the life death and resurrection of
Jesus in our place.
That he paid the price for our sins to remind us
of that to be changed by that.
Are someone compare it to one of those old Coke
machines?
Now sometimes when you would put your quarter in
there, it would get kind of stuck about two inches down in there.
So, what did you do?
You banged on the side over and over and over again until it
finally dropped down in there and you got your Coke out.
Kids, I know they do don't have coins anymore and
many machine I get that but it used to happen that way.
But that's what someone said that you have to do with the
gospel. We keep banging it into our heads
until it finally drops down into our hearts and produces the
good fruit that God wants it to produce.
We forget Paul Tripp said we have gospel amnesia.
And we just keep forgetting. This is who God is this is
what he's done and we've got to keep coming back to it
because the whole book of Mike.
Is the story of Judah for getting who God is?
Running off into all kinds of other things
trying to find life in
all those other things.
When they had already had life.
in him
They kept forgetting that God is who he
says he is in Exodus 34 verses 6
and 7.
God himself says the Lord Yahweh a
god merciful and gracious.
Slow to anger abounding and steadfast
love and faithfulness.
Keeping steadfast love for thousands forgiving iniquity
and transgression and sin.
But who will by no means clear the guilty.
Visiting the iniquity of the fathers and the children and the children's
children to the third and the fourth generation.
Micah wanted the people to remember that
That this is who our God is.
draw near to Him He blesses to thousands Generations
but if you turn away from him he's going to
Visit judgment on you and your children.
They needed to remember and be changed by
that picture.
That's why Micah in these three verses
at the end of chapter 7. He taught a master class and
who Yahweh is
He paints a beautiful picture.
Of even just two aspects of God's
character.
His mercy and his sovereignty.
That his mercy and sovereignty to facets of
the Lord that should lead us to a deep Abiding Love
for God.
But also a deep abiding faith in God.
Because this is why the Lord is so utterly unique.
among all the gods
first because he forgives our sin.
Who is like Yahweh?
That he forgives our sin.
I mean look again at this string of stunning forgiveness
metaphors.
Look at verses 18 and 19 Micah 7 again.
Who is a God Like You?
Pardoning iniquity and passing over transgression
for the remnant of his inheritance.
He does not retain his anger forever because he Delights in
steadfast love.
He will again have compassion on us. He'll tread our
iniquities our sins underfoot and he
will cast all our sins into the depths of the sea.
Like wow, right who is like Yahweh.
Just look at all that it says about him first he pardons
iniquity.
The image we get here is the removal of Sin from
someone and the putting of that sin on
someone else.
so that word means
it's what the suffering servant does in Isaiah 53.
We're in verse 4. It says he has borne our griefs and
carried our sorrows.
Leading to verse 11 where he shall bear their
iniquities.
That means he takes them off and puts them
on.
Off us on to him. That's the pardoning there.
In other words what that means is that someone must die for sin.
Either you or a sufficient substitute who
can pardon you.
He pardons God Yahweh pardons our iniquities.
He passes over transgression it says.
The image we get here is overlooking a fault.
Which essentially just means forgiveness, right?
Yes, you've done it but I'm going to overlook pass
over it. Now. This is not arbitrary doesn't happen
for everyone because it says this forgiveness is
only reserved for his remnant.
His inheritance meaning those who are his by
faith. That's who he forgives.
Keep going in chapter 7. He says God does not
retain his anger forever because he Delights instead
fast. Love.
Kids remember this whole series we've had this one Hebrew
word coming up that you got to get the throat into right? Yes
said, right that's this idea of steadfast love.
It shows up all over my cup. It actually shows up all
over the Old Testament, too.
Primary word to show God's merciful love
for his people.
Which fits well in this concept of pair of Pardon and
forgiveness, right?
It's merciful love. It's steadfast love.
I'm gonna love you no matter what.
But I want you to see something about this here.
Not only does God just tolerate has
said.
What does it say?
He Delights in it.
This this struck me this week really heavy. Have
you ever thought of God's mercy like that?
Have you ever thought of God's mercy in that way
that he is excited to forgive you.
I think what most of us grew up thinking is
our picture of God is one of disgust.
towards us
that he's up there just ticked off on us all the time.
But but do you see this?
This says he Delights in triumphing over judgment with
Mercy.
He Delights in that it's what Isaiah 30 Verse
18 says so beautifully therefore the
Lord waits to be gracious to you.
And therefore he exalts himself to show
Mercy to you.
For the Lord is a God of Justice. Yes.
But blessed are all those who wait for him.
Because he waits to show Grace to us.
This is steadfast love
don't think of him in the other way think of him as this way.
He's delighting and showing forgiveness to you.
And Micah says here's why because Yahweh has compassion
on his people.
That word compassion is a word that pictures how a mother yearns
for her child.
The idea that God yearns for his people. This
is his heart toward his people. He's not angry at
his people. He has Grace towards him. He wants
to show Mercy towards them.
There's even more to this Micah 7 also says
he Treads our iniquities our sins under his feet.
You've seen the the oak trees dropping their leaves and
the acorns right now. Imagine as you would
walk over those things and kind of crush them
under your feet as you're walking over your yard or over
the sidewalk. That's what God does with our
sins.
Crushing them under his feet.
It's what he does with our sins that he's not just like
averting his eyes and hoping he doesn't notice that
we've sinned. He's actually destroying them
like they're an enemy.
Because that's what they are, right? That's what sin is towards us. They
are an enemy to our soul sin is
something that keeps us from God. It is something that
destroys us and so God has to conquer
that to bring us back to him.
How does he do that?
By sweeping them under the rug and hoping that they don't or pushing
them in the closet and shoving that door closed and hope it doesn't explode
on no. That's not how he does it right? He does it through.
The perfect life death and resurrection of Jesus Christ in
our place paying the penalty for
our sin the full price of it and then
defeating it by coming back out of the Grave alive on
the third day.
That's how he conquers sin.
And if all that wasn't enough.
Micah 7:19 says God will cast
all our sins into the depths of the sea.
Which is a common phrase throughout the Old Testament. That means they
are completely gone.
And the image comes from The Exodus you remember how Pharaoh's Army
was chastened God's people out as they they
let him go but then they wanted him back and so they chased after
them and that the people of God are stuck behind between
the Red Sea in front of them and Pharaohs Army
behind them and they're like God, what are we going to do about this?
And God said watch.
Splits the sea open they walk through on dry land and Pharaoh's
Army starts coming through and what happens?
God destroys them.
But not only destroys them. He also throws them
into the depths of the sea.
Where they are never seen again.
That's the image.
Of what God does with our sin our greatest enemy.
He defeats it and throws it away.
Who is a God Like You?
Pardoning iniquity and passing over
transgression for the remnant of his inheritance.
He does not retain his anger forever because he
Delights instead fast. Love.
He will again have compassion on us. He will
tread our iniquities underfoot. You will
cast all our sins into the depths of
the sea. Is that not a beautiful picture of
forgiveness?
For a people like Judah who have been so wicked.
So far from God.
Just gives them hope.
That if they would just turn from their sin and turn to the Lord in faith.
He would forgive them.
He would restore them no matter how far they had
gone. He Delights in being merciful.
Same for you and me today.
Listen if you're sitting in shame right
now.
because of your past
or because of your present.
See the heart of God towards you.
See God's heart toward you.
So what Psalm 103?
Verses 11 through 13 says for as
high as the heavens are above the Earth. So great
is his steadfast love. There's that word
again toward those who fear Him
as far as the East is from the West so far.
Does he remove our transgressions from us?
As a father shows compassion to his children. So the
Lord shows compassion to those who fear
Him.
What that means is if you turn to Jesus in your
place, you have a compassionate father who
removes your sin.
And not only does he throw it into the bottom of the ocean. He also
separates you from it. As far as the East
is from the West.
Now now think about that for a second. Why does he not
say as far as the north is from the south?
Because when you think about the globe right no matter
what that NBA player says the Earth is not flat. It's a
globe right like so no matter how far you you can
go north eventually you hit the North Pole and
you go north and then you start going South again.
And you you hit the North Pole you go south you hit the South Pole you start going
north again. So if you say north to south the distance
is about 12,000 miles.
And you can make it that far eventually you can work from
north to south but think about it if you start going east.
You never hit West do you?
You go to infinity and beyond right East keeps going east.
All the way around and around that's as far as
the East is from the West.
That's what he does with your sin.
That's God's heart.
For those who turn to him in faith.
unbeliever
This is the most important thing you could ever hear in your life.
Not because I'm saying it to you but because this
is what God says to you.
The biggest problem in your life is not a
lack of Education a lack of
Economic Opportunity a lack of of relationships.
Whatever you might say. This
is my issue. The biggest problem in your life is that
you have sinned against a holy God and you if nothing else
changes you are due as judgment.
If I don't say that at arrogance because here's where.
Who we all still see that same God.
Who does Judge sin who is just and
righteous? He also has provided an
opportunity for you to be forgiven of your sins
through the blood of Jesus in your place.
Yes, this is true judgment. But there's also
this offering of the gift of mercy of
not giving you what you deserve because of
your sin of pardoning you taking your
sin off and putting it on Jesus.
And so that's that's you right now. I'm believer. So
right where you are if you see I need that in my life
right where you are. You can with your whole heart. You can
tell the Lord that you've sinned against him that you deserve his
judgment, but you want his forgiveness through Jesus.
And you say to him Jesus you are my only hope in life
and death. I have nothing else. I can't
do it. I need you.
Because this is the kind of God that he
is.
that he Delights in Mercy
So don't think you're too far don't think you're too
dirty. He Delights in taking someone
like you.
And making you his child.
Cleaning you up drawing you into his family. That's what
he does.
This is who he is.
But listen this also applies to you believer.
Because you might be sitting there in shame.
wallowing in your past
feeling unworthy feeling unloved.
hear me friend
this is your
God pardoning
passing over
delighting and mercy
showing compassion
crushing sin and treating us as
if he's completely forgotten our sin.
And so if you truly want him.
If you are truly repentant meaning you
see I am headed towards sin and destruction and
judgment and I don't want that anymore and I'm turning
towards him in faith. Not just kind
of saying I'm sorry God and keep going this way. I turn
to him. This is what he does.
And what that turning does and his filling does is it
gives you the strength to stop living in the bondage and
darkness of sin?
And you can instead live in this freedom.
Of dying to yourself and turning to
him and letting him live his life through you.
So listen believer, he's not up there.
disappointed in you
disgusted that you're not doing more for him.
Now he loves you Just the Way You Are.
You are his child.
But he also loves you too much to leave you where you are.
Because he's got so much more for you.
He's got so much more truly Abundant Life
for you to live that you were designed to
live. He's got more for you. So yes, he loves
you right where you are. Don't ever think that you have to earn his love.
He loves you and then he loves you too much to keep
you there.
Which is actually the promise that we get from verse 20.
in Micah 7
Micah's coming in on approach. He's almost done with this
Landing. He's looking to Yahweh. He's seeing
his character.
And in all of this Micah knew for certain that this
is a God who fulfills his promises?
Mercy, and sovereignty were the two things he's talking about and so
he said God forgives our sins and he fulfills
his promise. This means he never changes.
He never changes the same God who promised
to make Abraham a great nation through which
he'd bless. All the nations is the same God that would
be faithful to bring that promise about someday.
Listen, if you think that God's Gonna back out halfway down the
road to this thing. You've mistaken God.
now to Micah
and to the remnant it might have seemed.
Like God had given up.
But they went back to his promises.
They looked up they looked back. They said God is a
God who fulfills his promises Micah knew
God's character. He trusted in this Yahweh. So
even when he couldn't see the results, he said
I know who God is.
I know this is who God is and so I'm clinging to
him. It's the same for you and me.
No matter what you are facing no matter
what things look like around us. This is who
our God still is.
He is our salvation.
He's the God who promised all these things but
he's also the guy who came in the flesh to fulfill all
of these promises some we're going to celebrate over the next few weeks
with Advent with Christmas this Incarnation God In
the Flesh coming in glory to
say I'm going to come through on what
I said, I'm gonna come through on
and see this is the god who will one day restore as
Micah's prophesied. He says God is one day going
to restore that mountain.
As his dwelling place as the dwelling place of his
people with him and the only way up there is by God
bringing you up there with him.
but one day
it's all gonna be restored. It's all gonna be made right?
Who is a God Like You?
pardoning iniquity
and passing over transgression for the remnant of his inheritance.
He does not retain his anger forever because he Delights instead
fast. Love.
He will again have compassion on us. He will tread
our iniquities underfoot.
You will cast all our sins into the depths of the sea.
You will show faithfulness to Jacob instead fast.
Love to Abraham as you have sworn to our
fathers from the days of old.
Who is like Yahweh?
No.
And so come let us adore him.
And let us give our lives to him all day
every day.
Because he is worthy of it.